[Musique]
alors dans l'instant bien sûr on va on
va revenir sur penny pitié mais juste
avant on a quelqu'un qui est derrière
avec nous toutes les semaines et qui
s'intéresse aux autres saisons tp mpc
stan statham est avec nous avons là les
mots statham
alors mon chéri je peux tu nous a ramené
aujourd'hui tu es traité très chic
d'arette merci je suis un peu déçu parce
que la semaine dernière j'ai été
squizzée s'il a préféré un pamela
anderson à ma chronique je comprends
j'ai pas les mêmes arguments
du coup j'ai décidé de vous re conquérir
enfin de vous re conquérir comme dirait
qu a pu en gros vous faire l'amour par
l'image
arriba calme toi quand même d'accord
mais pour cela j'ai fouillé dans les
archives de tmp et revenons un nom en
arrière que se passait-il dans
l'émission eh bien rien d'anormal et
noura se faisait kage dessus par un
pigeon est logique et cyril lui sortait
d'une folle nuit d'amour avec le grand
schtroumpf
comme vous pouvez le voir juste derrière
moi si ça arrive ça arrive vous l'avez
compris tout l'esprit de tpm péter la
vraie tpm payer un an ça donnait ça
regardez
[Musique]
et il y un an cyril on sentait déjà que
tous les chroniqueurs vous respecter
énormément
julien courbet regardez là tant qu les
plus bas revenus
je vais te j'y vais très bien merci
isabelle moret tous en fait ce sont là
de vanité tard à sa merci
sinon l'année dernière et n'aura été
victime d'une terrible attaque de
pigeons
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il y un an cyril et la chorale de tpm
père prenait maître gims c'est l'heure
du baba ok
[Musique]
elle mange et ibm et apple fait
d'habiter voudrait une beauté sans
pareille
[Musique]
dormez dans une benne elle aimait le
pollen elle s'appelait s'appelle bel a
déjà va pas s'appeler bellens est pas d
serge helmes
zagury
il avait dû fumer déjà à l'époque on
voulait savoir pourquoi tpmc cartonne
année après année et bien c'est qu'on se
renouvelle tous les jours tenez par
exemple juste avant les vacances on a
fait le prime de la vérité il ya tout
pina non ça c'était un le prime de la
vérité aussi également toujours les
mêmes choses on sort nos malheurs toi
d'ailleurs pour cette émission c'était
pas emmerdé on avait recyclé le décor de
the voice
du coup quand mélanger deux émissions on
n'y voit que du feu voilà cyril hanouna
jury de the voice comme m pokora
regardez ce qu'ils feraient doux
c'est pas commentaire non plus bonsoir
comment vous appeler madame je m'appelle
audrey vous attendez pression ça va bien
je suis sûr ça mais là là c'est une meuf
normalement elle appelle toute une
histoire en anonyme normalement oui
donc là il faut que je choisisse c'est
ça oui donc c'est la merde mais on va
remonter dans le temps encore plus loin
en 2008 à une époque où cyril peser
encore 60 kg 60 kg de moins
qu'aujourd'hui
alors je retire alors si comme moi vous
rêvé de ressembler à cette espèce
d'avoir ce corps de rêve dessiné par les
dieux et je vais vous donner la recette
la formule mais juste avant cyril
promettez moi de ne pas me virer jamais
parce que toulon a dit à la rédac
tu es un ouf il va te dirai sur le
changer dit cyril il a de l'humour donc
non il n'a pas mesuré
écoutez plutôt la rédac vient écouter
c'est vrai c'était un plaisir merci t as
tu as fait une pub s'allumer beauté
aujourd'hui je vais vous révéler mon
secret régime
ça c'était moi avant j'étais mince j'ai
été beau gosse made moi c'est petit cul
là et puis j'ai suivi une cure de
bavards 3000 la barre protéines et qui
procure plus de calories qu'un couscous
royal et bing le gardien à un bon gros
loup cours la barre 3000 ça donne envie
de s'abonner 1
je leur ai je bien bas
on a quoi d'autres médias là vous l'êtes
aussi un petit bonus
j'ai un petit bonus et c'est un chiffre
le chiffre 0 2 0 à bâle le pain cuit
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est patrick moonen servat ont fait du
bien d'avoir la pression publique
mettrait notre actif la cendre ossature
à casser là ça lui fait du bien merci
le prix qu'il a perdu depuis ben non
plus non non le nom de bonnes vannes de
thierry moreau non plus 0 c'est le
nombre de fois où thierry moreau a fait
sa chronique depuis le retour des
vacances
ah oui vous savez pourquoi cyril lui a
retiré sa chronique non et ben moi j'ai
la réponse en fait thierry est un être
détestable dans la vie privée regardez
thierry moreau et le directeur de la
rédaction d'un magazine télé à la
télévision c'est un homme sympathique
jovial et polis mais en dehors des
plateaux
la vérité est tout autre encore un conte
qui me demandent un ami sur les réseaux
sociaux
c'est un bordel merde
casse toi oui comptez bonne toi quelle
boule
heureusement pour les équipes thierry
moreau devient raisonnable une fois dans
l'éloge de ses pmp es tu pourrais pas
monter un peu les pieds à pleaux je m'en
fous ferme à la fin de la ta gueule
alors il est où ce truc c'est parce que
oui thierry moreau est dans la vraie vie
un véritable [ __ ] ça fait du bien
alors ça t'emmerde
c'est la mascotte il recycle et magnéto
qui sont pas partis dans la semaine et
c'est pas fini
on l'avait pas vu bravo merci
[Applaudissements]